buenos días los países europeos ya están
preparando estas sanciones anunciadas ya
ayer tras el reconocimiento de estas dos
regiones separatistas por parte de rusia
aunque la aprobación final la
ratificación final y aprobación política
no se va a producir hasta esta tarde
-hora local- en que los cancilleres
europeos se reúnen de urgencia en parís
la mayoría de hecho ya se encuentra ya
en esta ciudad para poder abordar estas
posibles sanciones aún así el jefe de la
diplomacia europea joseph murray ha
recordado que hay que actuar con rapidez
y que algunas de estas sanciones ya
están preparadas va a haber reuniones
técnicas a lo largo de todo el día entre
parís y bruselas según fuentes
consultadas por france 24 este tipo de
sanciones serán selectivas contra
entidades y también contra individuos
tanto rusos como también de las regiones
de donets y lugares que puedan afectar a
las actividades de también sectores de
estas regiones la idea es sancionar de
forma clara de forma directa a estos
sectores de también a individuos que han
partido en la separación de estas
regiones porque la unión europea
considera que lo que ha ocurrido en las
últimas horas es una clara amenaza a la
soberanía de ucrania no hay duda entre
los países europeos de que hay que
sancionar ante esta situación pero la
pregunta es cuán lejos están dispuestos
a llegar los países europeos para
sancionar algunos países advierten que
aunque quieren quieren apoyar a ucrania
y también mostrar su solidaridad no es
lo mismo anexionarse a un territorio que
reconocer la independencia de unas
regiones así que los países europeos
tendrán que encontrar un equilibrio por
si quieren aún mantener la puerta
abierta a la vía diplomática algo que la
unión europea nunca ha rechazado en
cualquier caso los países europeos
insisten que actuarán con unidad y con
firmeza